ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata in cucina buttata summer edition
ma oggi faremo una di quelle cose che ho
sempre pensato di non poter fare a casa
in maniera buona buona buona e cosa
abbia pensato di dover per forza
acquistare da qualche parte sto parlando
dei ghiaccioli ne faremo di vari tipi
per sfruttando sempre lo stesso
procedimento quindi utilizzeremo frutta
fresca zucchero è bene faremo uno
speciale che abbiamo visto online e che
vogliamo provare salato come forma per
scelto questo cosino qui che abbiamo
trovato su amazon se volete comprare
anche voi vi lasciamo il link qui sotto
in descrizione che secondo me li fa
super carini perché le fa mini e
soprattutto permette di farne tanti di
vari colori partiamo subito con gli
ingredienti per fare il ghiaccio della
frutta avremo bisogno di acqua zucchero
pompelmo rosa arancia limone kiwi
fragole e more partiamo col primo colore
che vuole orientare che quello lì del
pompelmo rosa erano solo cene momento
andremo a tagliare e utilizzeremo la
polpa interna senza non con spremerla
voglio provare una cosa perché non
l'avesse capito vogliamo provare una
ricetta a occhio naga cielo si muove non
spremiamo perché voglio provare poi a
passarlo al colino e soprattutto quando
tagliamo andiamo dedicati per evitare di
perderci succo mettiamo la frutta dentro
un pentolino un paio di zucchero e
mettiamo tutto quanto sulla fiamma la
cosa importante da fare è schiacciare
inizialmente bene il frutto affinché
rilasci un pochino di succo e permetta
lo zucchero di sciogliersi in questo
succo e quindi non andare direttamente
sulla padella caramellare si è chiaro
così dicendo non stesso asportando
intanto che questo va io ho partire
subito con l'altro così ci riportiamo a
casa più velocemente siamo d'accordo
intanto della giraglia se vuoi se vai 1
st marmellate mar me la tipica trigila
mar nella tipica la marmellata non
riesco a verificare
questo video ha commentato con la
marmellata di fichi la marne la critica
dirige marmo e latifi khatri ceo kay de
roma verona piani avete la sua casa
bella regata
[Risate]
passiamo ai kiwi di quart e pinocchio a
simone guardero il negozio sono
arrabbiato così e ora christian guarda
ke io so che alcuni mangiano i kiwi con
la buccia è immagino con la cucina ma
non esiste ma cosa ma ragazzi qualcuno
tra voi mangia il kiwi con la buccia
vibrafono sapere perché un talento
aggiungiamo un po di zucche o al kiwi
avendo anche un pochino una consistenza
più coriacea secondo me ha bisogno di un
cecchino di limone abbiamo il nostro
primo composto lo mettiamo all'interno
dello sco lino e separiamo la polpa dal
succo e basta
perdiamo un po di acqua ed era
aggiungiamo
diciamo che una reazione naturale dalla
mano di filiazione l'italia mi sento
male ma visto che curiosità dei costi
che avevamo letto su internet che
avrebbe fatto vedere in foto
fragole al volo
guardate questi occhi sono cattivi
demoniaco e così demoniaco con la
fragola sto tranquillo l'afragola ci
viene da dio però la viva l'attenzione
su internet è una reazione naturale
allora ragazzi cerchiamo limitarci a
casa questo nostalgiche secondo me se
devo la pensa così tanto
oppure si fa più acqua mamma mia che mi
piacciono
questo che domani idee tu sei troppo
veloci giudicare io dico un po
[Musica]
passiamo a questo punto all'arancia così
salle grover radioso e che si guarda
sono pazzo premiamo l'arancia abbiamo
uno spreme volumetto questo sto
spronando la forchetta che devo sapere
perché abbiamo messo il proprio il
mentire l'arancia la stiamo strumento
perché
faccio una domanda più facile di che
segno sei cari sagittario gratis
evidente potevamo spendere con per
morero giro io che ho fatto un lavorone
comitini sudicio ma perché io sono gli
schizzi della tua tutta di mandati ove
docente dello stesso soggetto
adesso ti faccio vedere cosa è peggio ho
appena visto questa bottiglia stupenda
tra le scorte di una linea che un whisky
devozionale
ma pensate che ripeto io penso che la
decadenza da una sentenza
iscriviti porta dell'inferno ma questa
favetta è normale che ci mettiamo al pc
cup juve che sta avvenendo gli altri la
mia è ora un limone a pieno carico di
zucchero e best coast che curioso bene
questo procedimento ama me lo staff
apposta a nascondermi la critica che
adesso passiamo alle more del miur che
ebbe tantissime a mamma mia
vediamo giocare con miccoli
non ce la fa più vedere lo stesso
procedimento all'infinito enrico voglio
sempre ricordarti che io invece ho
assistito ad uno shooting composto
dentro la gente non c'è ogni volta
passato un'ora l'uno e l'altra qui
ciliegia marcos amoled di tipo il turno
di notte la guardia signora giovanna
brava gira quella di quell'altra metto
in realtà anche questa volta di
partecipare a questo forno a caso è
finito in acqua
adesso sto facendo le cose senza kacar
minare tu sei bravissimo mi sto perdendo
tutto passiamo alla ricetta segreta per
il ghiacciolo salato segreto avremo
bisogno dei cinque tutto nella regione
dello zucchero
brutta bestia o più istituti è arrivato
il mondo non vedeva l'ora che accadesse
prendiamo l'acqua e poi aggiungere lo
zucchero sul fuoco prendiamo i
pomodorini mettiamo all'interno di una
brocca come è stata ricreata gianmarco
ci vogliamo uccidere un giorno gioco che
sta facendo la stessa cosa all'infinito
[Applauso]
filtri hanno tutto quanto lei servire
per bene è tra g incubo non ricordo da
casa se lo rifà the fate un gusto solo
abbiamo il succo di pomodoro a questo
punto olio sale da ieri gaillard detto
stone tabasco queste tra forte e ragazzi
chi lo beve muore no ragazze capita a me
memoria ragazza a 100.000 light la vigna
mangerà la comi dove c'è in area milioni
della lega troppo come troppo per la mia
vita è troppo a piegare anche ma guarda
tu no no no no mai
lo faccio ma lo faccio davanti al
policlinico umberto primo
a metà seduta prendiamo questo punto lo
sciroppo un paio di cucchiai mischia
come siamo messi a un mese ma stiamo sta
buono buono non riesco a immaginarlo
freddo da una roba buonissimo e alla
messa in basilica
vedi un assaggiata ma che fecero è
squisito foglioline di basilico ce lo
nascondiamo attenta a questo punto la
parte più divertente la scelta dei
colori pensavo di dare al verde li perde
no siamo tutti diversi questo col nero
ma questo al limone diremo questo punto
cioè di avere messi così antonica
meccanici sotto il ponte manco me
pensavo che tutto quanto
guarda su simone aspettiamo ora mi terrò
verso quello che mette di più che quello
l'arancia è questo quello che voleva
stare e vero no no fra la livello
tecnico non li guarda che lo vede che
c'è una fontanina amico ti fanno
popolando quindi sarò breve grazie
lo aspetto di questo è molto carino
proprio rosso rosso alcuni di questi
sono veramente carini ragazzi hanno un
problema di ghiacci che hanno subito
questo questo già un po meno ma non
molto molto molto carino do un sette e
mezzo forse di più un sette e mezzo
questo e da due d'arechi sette e mezza
di 88 è veramente brutto brutto brutto
non lasciarli co autore senza sole
l'odore della fragola e kiko dei bacini
che ora una inesistente
sì ma no non è sufficiente l'odore
quattro e mezzo 5 e mezzo alcuni sono da
sette altri sono per questo caso a 12
sabato 5 io sono curiosissimo di
assaggiare questo che è quello salato
partiamo con l'assaggio limone vediamo
che succede
quest'anno sciogliere abbastanza forte
come sapore anti equa ci sta pure un
semino facciano parte della ricetta
croci netto di solito dentro ghiaccioni
se meno allora assaggio anche il kiwi è
buonissimo allora un quanto ha sapore
secondo me l'effetto sorpresa di un
ghiacciolo salato zona 6 e mezzo
alla mora no 9 acidulo però non malvagio
a favore di questo 6 il meno 8 assaggio
il pompelmo rosa fragola mi incuriosisce
molto di più
allora oddio
[Risate]
molto interessante anche come
consistenza si è tenuto molto meglio e
polpa congelata capito che intendo
questo top set fallimentare non è un
ghiacciolo vito 43 e mezzo anzi quanto
pagare per questo un euro pagherà un
euro e mezzo ne comprerei 52 dove
sfondare 12 ognuno di questi un euro e
mezzo quello sull ato 2 euro perché è
una novità
stiamo proprio facendo una rapina
vogliamo farla per forza 2 euro un euro
al pezzo ne vuoi uno quasi uno per collo
salato ok ragazzi sono arrivati alla
fine di questo video spero che mi sia
piaciuto come sempre richiede di
scrivere per questo canale tirare a
campare notifiche metterci un bel live
soprattutto facci sapere come state
passando queste vacanze ristabilire al
cantone sta divertendo che state facendo
successe cose strane e tutto sta andando
normalmente state riuscendo a fare
vacanze oppure stato ancora rimasti a
qualche parte oppure siete tornati già
dalle vostre vacanze io come sempre vi
mando un bacio grande e ci vediamo
giovedì con un ovvio